I think the average person imagines the
Pirates with a hook for a hand
race big floppy hat blue you know
waistcoats and maybe even a peg leg
Jared on the shoulder here this
particular gang of pirates were active
in a very early part of the 18th century
for only four or five years but they
included Blackbeard black Sam Bellamy
Steve bonnets the women pirates Mary
Whedon and Bonnie were all part of this
one gang that's this gang that all of
the pop culture images and iconography
relating the pirates comes from one of
the most common oceanic sailing routes
or English seamen was to go from England
to the Caribbean because that was a
major route of merchant shipping and so
they would come back to gray dreary
England and one of the things they would
bring with them often were these
colorful birds from the tropics
especially parrots who could be trained
to sit on your shoulder but also to
actually speak words and you can imagine
how boring it must have been on their
off hours what are you going to do the
colorful and talkative parrots were
treasured both as a form of
entertainment and recreation all of the
artistic pirates had because you know
having a parrot as a pet missing arms
eyes and hands and so forth was very
common among sailors in that time period
most pirates had been merchants or naval
sailors prior to going into piracy and
the big piracy outbreak was prompted by
the ending of a big colonial war the war
of Spanish secession you had thousands
of people without means to sustain
themselves and and with a special skill
set the pressures on sailors were
enormous so many of them mutant need and
took over their vessels these pirates
from Golden Age of piracy were folk
heroes at the time they were still alive
they argued they weren't beach and
brigands they said that they were
engaged essentially a social revolt
against the ship captains and ship
owners he made ordinary sailors lives
miserable that they were Robin Hood
figures you know
robbing from the wicked rich the federal
source many of them had been in
accidents because being a sailor whether
a pirate or not aboard a ship was a very
dangerous proposition
rigging fell in storms cargo and barrel
shifted around in battle you will be hit
by wood splinters or who knows what else
so lots and lots of pirates sailors also
may have had eyepatch --is and the pig
legs and hooks or other things for arms
because they lost their eyes or limbs in
these various accidents during combat
so pirates probably looked a little bit
like some crazy scene from you know the
early Mad Max movies a bunch of people
bizarrely dressed like a
post-apocalyptic image and you know that
was precisely the idea especially
Blackbeard was to cultivate a image of
terror so that everyone would be so
scared of them they'd surrender without
a fight
but in all the accounts of all of
Blackbeard raids and captures of ships
he threatens a lot of people but never
actually killed anybody
prior to his final fatal battle with a
Royal Navy